if my family was a week I'd be Wednesday
did Jenna Ortega manifest her role in
Netflix's Wednesday it just felt
appropriate but I do best
yeah fans seem to think the actress
predicted she'd take on Wednesday Adams
in the highly praised series and it's
all because this viral clip resurfaced
from Disney Channel's Stuck in the
Middle this is what happens when there
are seven kids and you're stuck in the
middle if my family was a week I'd be
Wednesday naturally the internet's gone
into a frenzy over the foreshadowing
correct I just knew that this is
probably what I should do but fans may
want to slow their role Jenna told ET
that getting cast was actually a big
shock to her I don't think I really
processed I was at work at the time and
they talked to me and I was like
um yeah let's talk about it later and
then later just kept happening and then
before I knew it it was like May and
they were flying me out to London to go
start hair makeup test and that's when I
thought oh
I'm about to do a job for the next eight
months I have no interest in following
in your footsteps and it's not the first
time fans have spotted similarities
between Jenna and the Grim teen
Wednesday I've always been compared to
and it's weird because you never really
you sign on to this job but you never
really anticipate being offered or even
being in the run for jobs like these
with you know such icons and legendary
characters yeah it's it's pretty cool it
kind of felt like a fever dream honestly
I bet this place won't be any different
Jenna's Wednesday is breaking streaming
records with over 340 million hours
viewed in its first week I'm not used to
people engaging with me there was a lot
of challenges you know because it's uh
we've never seen her as a teenage girl
before we've never spent so much time
with Wednesday on character so doing an
emotional Arc with someone who's usually
the one-liner you know it's it's
introducing the audience to a new
version also yeah it's a modern take
right you know it's a different world
it's a different environment we've never
seen the atoms in this world before so
there's a lot of that and then there's a
lot of cooks in the kitchen multiple
directors giving their own opinions so I
really learned how to put my foot down
and kind of speak up for the character
which for that I'm very proud of the
series also features the OG Wednesday
atoms played by Christina Ricci this
time as Ms Marilyn Thornhill good
evening girls I'm Miss Thornhill I trust
Enid has given you the old Nevermore
welcome it was scary I'm not gonna lie
yeah because it's like you know she's
observing what it is that you're doing
and it is one of her more popular
characters and I don't know it's she's
created quite the Legacy to live up to
and the show is very reminiscent of her
take and and yeah you just want to show
that there's respect there well one
thing we know for sure Jen is nailing it
as the face of our favorite angsty
murder mystery solving team I know it's
pretty cool
[Music]